[Music]
this morning on a dish a chef who grew
up in southern heat and put it in a
bottle
Jeff Rhine was raised in the red clay
fields of Georgia during a break from
college he got a restaurant job in South
Carolina and made cooking his career
with stops at top venues there and in
the Midwest along the way he noticed
that bottles of the hot sauce he created
kept disappearing from restaurant tables
so he decided to help customers acquire
them legitimately to come out of the
kitchen to manufacture his red clay hot
sauce line now available nationwide chef
Jeff good morning and welcome to the
dish good morning grateful to be here
thank y'all for having me it's tough
what are we having front of us here
we've got a little fall southern brunch
so starting on our right we've got some
stone or steel cut oats with caramelized
apples and pears toasted almonds and
some of our hot honey
then we got some candied bacon I would
give a pro tip here you might want to
get a piece of candied bacon and put it
in your Bloody Mary that we'll get to in
a second we got some coastal crab cakes
over some blistered okra and red clay
aioli we have a grits in the style of
how I like my hash browns at Waffle
House so scattered smothered covered
chunked in diced which just means
caramelized onions tomatoes bacon and
cheese and then we have a winter citrus
salad here with a varietal of winter
citrus fennel radishes this is my G
mama's pound cake they had pecan trees
in the yard so you still running around
picking those up have them with the
pound cake and some shrimp Chantilly
cream and then a Bloody Mary with the
big-business yeah that's right my
friends high wire distillery down there
they're vodkas fantastic for this with
the lover of hot sauce I'm gonna grab
one of my favorite dish presentations
yes it's awesome really great something
to gather around the table - did you
grow up loving food I did I spent a lot
of time in South Georgia in a little
town called elavil with my grandparents
and they were very good cooks so
anything from going out to the to the
yard and picking up pecans or farm-fresh
eggs or my great-grandfather was a
watermelon farmer so foods always been a
part of me I lost the story behind red
clay this really was by happenstance
yeah it was absolutely organic so
Charleston is a great food community I
was making hot sauce and summer
restaurants ended up taking it to the
next level because people were stealing
it off the table in the restaurant
so to your point about legitimizing it I
don't really want people to get arrested
for hot sauce we we legitimize the
business I started making it in my
garage in bourbon barrels and slowly
we've grown over the past five years to
actually making it more of a legitimate
process making it with proper
manufacturers but still holding true to
our values
I'm heading to Charleston's afternoon oh
yeah fantastic right on fantastic and
and when you develop the hot sauce what
do you what are you trying to create
what do you what are you sensing right
that's a fair point because I think the
market is very saturated but it's not
saturated by things that are focused on
being delicious so much of the markets
just trying to be hot and we approached
it from a chef's mentality where we're
trying to like create nuance we're
trying to accentuate the foods that
you're eating not overpower it because
if you're gonna spend a lot of time in
the kitchen the last thing you want to
do is dump something on it and ruin the
whole thing
all right all about the tank absolutely
the red sauce is my favorite just also
no awesome but I would imagine you were
in the kitchen and you were successful
making the transition you had to think
twice about didn't you yeah I mean it
takes a leap of faith fortunately for me
I had a driver and family that took me
out of the kitchen the chef's life is
difficult my wife's a teacher so trying
to balance that work-life balance as
being a chef was difficult so I have
three little kids now and they're
they're my primary focus so I wanted to
step away from the kitchen take a leap
of faith on red clay and see where we
could take it well as you think about
that and as you sign our dish if there's
anyone you'd love to share this meal
with who would it be I would actually
say someone pretty contemporary and Joe
Rogan I loved his I think he would
really enjoy some of our sauce line and
I feel like the dialogue that he's happy
yeah it's super cool so I'd love to have
a have a meal with him I think he'd
probably go for that bacon over there
chef Ryan we thank you thanks for
signing our dish and for more on him and
the dish head to our website at CBS this
morning calm